I don't want to go yes the time has at
last come to close out the run of David
Tennant has the doctor with the end of
time parts 1 & 2 together I do two
parters is one story so this is an
interesting one to go into because I
know that I know actually in fairly
heavy detail a lot of the things about
this that drive people some people nuts
there are certain fans who really don't
like this story for the most part I do
it over indulges in a few areas and some
of the stuff that I actually don't mind
or even like I do get why other people
don't enjoy it but this is Davies
blowing out what he does with Doctor Who
he does character drama that's what this
is that's what this leans heavily on
this is what it spends a lot of time
really amping up in various ways and
various levels some may feel it's
overdone but I feel what do you think
it's a bit too much or not it's pretty
dang fitting as an end for the Davies
era so this entire thing with the master
is now back oh yes spoilers you should
know all this I'm digging right into
this thing you know the Masters back
threat of Gallifrey coming back the Time
Lords actually seeing them they pretty
much almost make it wilfer's the
companion Tennant himself the cactus
people the vinvocci I know what they're
called don't call them cactuses that's
racist and a lot of absurdity and a very
prolonged goodbyes much in the vein of
like say or turn to the king so where to
begin well why don't I start with the
master I know that a lot of people seems
like particularly classic who fans but
not exclusively them really don't like
this take on the master they don't like
the insane metabolism where he's eating
people they don't like the lightening
powers they don't like how bonkers crazy
he is I like this better than John Simm
in Series three I'm still wouldn't call
it a great master but I find this way
more compelling than what they were
doing with him previously because what
they were doing before is they were
having him engaging in what were
supposed to be well thought out
carefully constructive planned ins and
yet bouncing around like a Looney Tunes
cartoon here he's acting crazy like he
doesn't have a plan that he couldn't
have cobbled together in like the last
hour and for the way he's behaving that
fits and I actually think the whole
thing about you know his body's falling
apart and you know he needs I mean the
the idea that he's actually eating
people and it's a little silly but like
I don't have a problem with that issue I
don't problem with like the skeletal
shifting I don't really have a problem
with the lightening again it's yes it's
ridiculous but the really the only
element about this that is a little much
for me is how we get him back in the
first place because so hold on in
addition to everything else he was doing
pretending to be Harold Saxon
setting up the Archangel Network so that
nobody realized what he was and bought
his story and creating that fake story
and getting himself into a political
position and negotiating with the takla
Fame and everything else he also started
up a cult that we never run into up to
this point the cults of sack
and that's using what it's I'm sorry
it's a magic potion and a magic ring and
yes I know the old adage any technology
sufficiently advanced enough will appear
like magic I know that but like this is
operating like magic and sometimes I can
accept that on Doctor Who depending on
what the source is when you introduce to
me a brand new species that I've never
had to deal with before I'm prepared to
accept that they are capable of
something that's gonna look to me like
magic I mean I don't love the
carrionites but it's kind of the basis
by which they work but with the master
who's a Time Lord who they don't do
stuff that just seems like magic for the
most part not like this not potions
yeah that's getting you back in the
first place is a tough pill to swallow
for me if I have I'm being completely
honest just because the method they used
to get us there
what's his back I like him I like the
energy that John Simm brings to this
particular iteration I really like some
of the moments where he really plays up
the isolation of his madness I I adore
him you know getting closer to the
doctor putting their heads together so
that the doctor hears the drumming and
when the doctor says he hurt hears that
the master just like he can barely
believe it and like that I love all that
I think that is great stuff and as far
as his plan goes yeah it's ridiculous
but the piece of technology that runs at
you manages to come across is utterly
ridiculous and I certainly have no more
issue with this than like what he tried
to do in Lagavulin the tail end of
Legolas was actually I didn't buy that
at all but now this works for me I enjoy
him here um so for me she's actually a
highlight again I know a lot of people
don't like this this particular
performance of the master at all even
folks we like John Simm I like it it
works for me
I wouldn't want like it work
here's a one-off I should clarify that
this is not like what I would want the
masa to be in future performances but
like as a one-off as a this is the
master completely unhinged and falling
apart yeah yeah this works for me and
you know obviously Tennant is bringing
is all to this he's bringing the he's
bringing the fun he's got some good
dialog he's bringing the fields plenty
of opportunities for him to do that
I shouldn't even really need to point
out that tenants just really really good
in this part at this point if you don't
already believe that by the time he's
done that nothing I say he's gonna
change your mind anyway he's really good
he sells everything that he's given to
do whether it is his anger his fear his
frustration in fact somewhat some of the
things I think he maybe sells a little
too well but I'll get into some of that
a little bit later
yes Cass is fine you know we have the
characters like like Naismith and and
his daughter and and you know they're
functional as sort of intermediary
villains we've got the vinvocci they're
fun actually I like them a lot I like
the whole thing with the shimmer and the
darker almost kind of mocking them with
it that that they thought they could get
away with with it around him and I also
actually really like that they neither
join in the fight at the end nor are
they in any way punished for fleeing cuz
normally in a story like this not always
doctor who although yeah sometimes a
doctor who I'm thinking of like the
marketing girl in Planet of you'd
usually characters who have the choice
you either join or flee and choose to
flee end up dying it's like well huh
yeah you know what you should have done
now right but that's not the case here
they're like okay we're gone and they're
gone and that's totally fine that works
for me
the Timelords coming back it there's
elements of it that I'm iffy on but I
mean can can I just say I love the fact
that the the thing opens with this
voiceover from this commanding voice
we've never heard before and then to
realize at the end that not only is it
Timothy Dalton
yes it's Emily Dalton
heading up the the Timelords
ultimately identified as Rassilon yes
again and I know some people mock like
the amount of spittle that comes off him
I'm you know to Gallifrey to victory I'm
sorry that is what happens when you have
a voice is powerful as Timothy Dalton's
and you enunciate properly I mean it's
it's like a classic adage of trying to
do Shakespeare if you enunciate that
kind of language properly the your scene
partner is gonna have a nice lovely
coating of saliva on them it's what
happens and I kind of love that it's
captured on film now like does Rassilon
make a ton of sense and everything else
well enough for the purpose of the
story's story I think I've seen some
people be like that's not how Rassilon
should behave let's be honest we've
never actually encountered Rassilon in
person up until this point I mean I may
be turned up in a book somewhere along
the way but I've said before that I
don't put two my second and the
callosity of those but we certainly have
things that we've been told about
Rassilon which is kind of why I like him
being identified as wrestling because
this would mean that this is the reality
behind the the canonized myth it's like
the Time Lords have their myth of this
great founder of their society and then
we meet him and it's like oh dang and I
kind of like that notion anyways getting
Donna back was a bit iffy and it is a
little weird that she doesn't really get
to share any scenes with Tennant not
really but it's still nice to have her
back it's nice to by the end I'll do
Millie see her happy
or as happy as she's ever gonna be not
traveling with the doctor but I mean
I've kind of been putting off let's talk
the true MVP of this story
it is Wilf Bernard Cribbins is amazing
and this why I'm honestly not sure the
story would
worked without him he is sweet and funny
and heartbreaking I think most Doctor
Who fans have at least one part of this
entire thing that makes them cry and I
know for a lot of people it's the I
don't want to go that doesn't make me
cry not even like when I first saw it it
didn't make me cry you know it does make
me cry though wilf giving that last
salute and you see the tears welling up
and yeah and prior to that he breaks my
heart trying to give the the doctor the
gun breaking down begging him to take it
huh Wilf is so good national treasure
that man the character maybe um Bernard
Cribbins to I don't know enough about
his work outside doctor but oh my god oh
my god so there are some other things
that are a little bit could use some
work let's talk about stuff that goes on
towards the end I am NOT a huge fan of
Tennant's hissy fit once he realizes
that in order to save Wilf he's going to
have to sacrifice himself and he has
this whole it's not fair I could have
done so much more and I don't love that
now it's not out of character for
Tennant as we've come to understand him
I buy it it's not that I don't believe
it
it's not that it's not justified I just
don't like it there's something about
the doctor being that petulant that
whiny that human I got the very end I
feel like the regeneration story should
should bring us the doctor at his best
and
getting this one more even though tenon
you know works his way through and comes
out the other end okay seeing this one
last glimpse basically this doctor at
his worst I don't love it and it's not
helped by the fact that in part one he
has the whole conversation with wealth
about dreading regeneration because
prior to this conversation
regeneration has never in universe been
treated like a death obviously for fans
it can be that way but within the story
the doctor is always comforting if he's
explaining regeneration to someone you
know the moment has been prepared for
yeah all that sort of stuff did he's
reassuring he's not going oh what was me
I'm basically gonna die even though I'm
not really like what and again it does
suit this particular doctor to take it a
bit more personally and take it in a
more human manner and liking it to
standard death a bit more but again I I
get it but I also just don't like it
especially and again not because the
tenant doesn't play well he plays it
great it's not a fan now as far as the
extended all the goodbyes that that
whole farewell tour I'm actually okay
with it I know it but I know again it
bugs some people I will say some of the
specific beats don't really work um the
big one for me is the one with Mickey
and Martha because I'm sorry that comes
literally out of nowhere like did they
did we even see them meet each other
like properly before I guess they were
in the TARDIS together in journey's end
for like a hot minute oh I guess we did
see Mickey walk off with Martha and Jack
at the end of that but still like that
that is a big leap especially given that
we knew Martha was engaged
to somebody else prior to this that all
of a sudden she and Mickey are married
no no I'm not saying that there's no way
I could ever buy it but for what we've
seen what we don't know that just seems
cheap and dumb and I don't I don't want
to accuse the show of doing this but I
it's the first thing that comes to my
mind is like oh the two black characters
get married because of course and it
probably wasn't on purpose but it just
it's weird it's weird and it's unearned
and it's it doesn't really work the
goodbye to Sarah Jane it's brief I like
it the goodbye to Jack well it's kind of
a nice note especially you know I don't
know if this aired I think this would
have aired after children of earth but
definitely internal chronology it's
after children of Earth and it's nice to
see Jack you know having something a
little comfort that's nice I actually
really like the thing with um with the
granddaughter of nurse Redfern that
actually works for me really well I find
that very sweet the little thing with
Rose pretty much works for me
it actually where it starts to get
indulgent again for me isn't in the
farewell tour because in many would like
none of these are characters we've seen
since this and you know maybe um the
show and the people involved knew that
was gonna be the case that Moffat was
gonna be dealing pretty much wholly with
with new characters maybe they didn't
know but even if it was just a way to
sort of sign off this era it to me it
did that makes sense it feels earned it
gets self-indulgent after that last
farewell to Rose and he has this sort of
get to get back to the TARDIS and it's
really prolonged and we have that I
don't want to go which I also think is a
little bit much and so like that bit
doesn't work but the farewell tour in
general yeah by that that works okay so
because of how long this thing is and
how many things go on it I do have notes
because I I don't want to miss like the
little things that like I kind of caught
it let me see what I didn't mention oh
it was very odd to me that they meant
that they referenced the real-life
president that
they actually named him as President
Obama and they kind of got a sort of
look alike
I think that's weird to me cuz doctor
has never referenced real-life political
figures before it ends up doing it again
later on with Trump but you know I'm
pretty sure this is the first time it's
weird to me I'm not a not a huge fan of
that I mean I guess I kind of get why
given that you know historically this is
very clearly our world yet he's not
encountering our political figures but I
don't know it's just weird to me okay I
I want to talk briefly about how
prophecy gets used in this story because
it includes examples both of an example
of what I think where prophecy works
really well and then embodying why 99
times out of a hundred I hate the use of
prophecy and narrative here's what I
like really well the he will knock four
times first of all I like the prophecy
in and of itself because it is
incredibly vague it's not clear who it's
referring to what they're knocking on
the context nothing and I like that and
obviously we have a huge red herring in
the master because you know he's got
that that beat in his head that for that
four-time beat you know and he even in
the junkyard he bangs that sort of that
that drum yeah the big steel drum four
times and like it's everything is
signposted that it's the master so I
really like that the knocking just ends
up being something as innocuous it's
just wolf behind the glasses hey ki can
you let me out I like that I like the
misdirection of it and I more than
anything I like that the doctor and I
guess yogi tells Wilf but the doctor is
the only one who knows it because my big
issue with prophecy more often than not
is it's used in place of proper
character motivation and it just has
people behave in a way because
the prophecy said they were always gonna
do that or they go oh the prophecy says
this well I have to be sure that that I
you know do this to make sure that it
happens or makes you know they're
they're behaving in a way strictly
because of the prophecy being in place
so it it it's a MacGuffin
I don't like prophecies as MacGuffin and
the four knocks I don't feel is that the
soothsayer who we get in part too
you know who's weird and bonkers in that
scribbles on her face everything that
she spouts and the talking of a prophecy
there with the Council of the Time Lords
that that is the stuff that I don't like
and I don't enjoy oh my oh stop so it's
funny to me that this ends up having
both sort of kind of elements of
prophecy that that can work for me or
where it usually doesn't so that was
kind of that was kind of an interesting
thing
oh and coming back to Wilfred the
knocking that whole nuclear vault thing
is preposterous like what why why would
you ever set up a system like that like
I get it in terms of the it always has
to be manned and one person can't get
out till another person hits the thing
on the other side I get that because it
means it's impossible for no one to be
in for it to be unmanned at any given
time on there always has to be someone
there because only the next shift can
let you out I get that but why why would
the radiation vent through the vault
controls and like the ISIS things like
vinvocci glass it'll contain the
radiation well if it can do that why
don't you have a separate like radiation
cage like it it's ridiculous but it's
also reverse engineering from the fact
that they had to create a scenario where
the only thing that could save Wilf was
the doctor doing something
self-sacrifice and that's what they came
up with but it's it's ridiculous on its
face so we've got that that said like I
do kind of like that the show kind of
hangs a lampshade on the massive
coincidences and the
dr. pointing out you know will few keep
rent we keep running into each other
that shouldn't be happening oh the woman
now the woman that wolf encounters a few
times and who the doctor sees at the end
now the big thing that I like about her
is in the episode itself we are not told
who this is
and I love that man I'm also well aware
that Russell T Davies and the other
producers are of the opinion was their
intention that that is the doctor's
mother
and that is fine that's their headcanon
but they didn't make it explicit in the
show so I don't have to accept that and
I get to choose to believe that that's
Romana and if you would rather it be
somebody else you can believe that
I like that enough is laid out that
someone who knows the doctor who cares
about him that he cares about back and
who's who's seeing will sort of give him
the strength to do what is right but who
that is
you decide I like it I like it a lot
what other little notes did I have oh I
like to win the when there's a couple
there's a couple of cute little touches
when the master like clones himself into
and to everybody which is a little
ridiculous but like it's fun ridiculous
that bit these distinctions are
arbitrary by the way between ridiculous
I can't swallow it and fun ridiculous
I'm I know there's no consistency here
it's just how it parses out for me but I
like that in some of the shots it's very
clear that the clothes don't fit him
because the the person whose body took
over was larger or smaller I like that I
also like that the master doesn't argue
with himself because normally in this
sort of setup especially with the
villain you would expect you know him to
start fighting he'd start having power
struggles with themselves some being
like why should you get to boss us
around just cuz you're the original none
of that and I kind of I kind of like
that because I would have expected the
other thing I think that's most of the
little notes I had
I think this is a good closure I don't
think it's the best finale
Davies ever did it's not his best work
but it does feel like the proper final
note in a lot of ways you know bringing
back the master one more time touching
on the time lords you know in a way that
the show hadn't done up to that point
having this celebration at the end with
the with the farewell tour it it feels
appropriate as an ender so for me it
works there are there's weirdness and
there's things I don't love but yeah it
was a good ending I think but I also get
why it really why certain aspects really
bug some fans but that'll be it for this
one folks and a miss the suit end of
time you've seen it would you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it a bunch of stuff to do down
there as well
there's the like and the subscribe both
of which are greatly appreciated there's
the patreon super appreciated it helps
keep the channel going and improve it
and help me cover my bills being
completely honest but there's that
there's socials there's the usual stuff
it's all down in the description give it
a look give it a click or don't I'm not
gonna tell you what to do because at the
end of the day folks it's you who are
the council and I am simply running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]